a new report suggests Google has been
secretly collecting the personal health
records of millions of Americans
according to The Wall Street Journal the
effort is codenamed project nightingale
that reportedly involves a deal made
last year with ascension a leading
nonprofit health system which includes
more than 2600 facilities in 21 states
patients and doctors were not notified
our dr. taryn Rula is here Tara good
morning what are the concerns here are
there violations is it legal good
morning Tony
so ascension says the work it's doing
with Google is compliant with HIPAA the
federal patient privacy law the
companies say the goal of this data
collection is to provide better care to
patients since it's just getting
reported now the program is creating
major privacy concerns the multi-billion
dollar healthcare industry has long been
on the radar for tech behemoth Google
and now it's in it in a big way as first
reported in The Wall Street Journal
ascension is sharing information with
Google a health system that includes
over 2,600 hospitals and health care
centers in 21 states in the program
called Project nightingale ascension is
reportedly providing patient names and
dates of birth as well as lab results
hospitalizations and diagnosis to Google
Google is using the information in part
to help ascension centralize its patient
database as well as design new software
that will use artificial intelligence to
predict or identify medical conditions
there are huge advantages in digital
health information pam dixon is with the
world privacy forum and says digital
records are necessary so is knowing
exactly what companies are doing with
such personal and private information
and how they are protecting it leaks of
private medical information are enormous
ly common the Department of Health and
Human Services actually tracks all of
the medical data breaches and actually
some of the largest data breaches in
history have been medical data breaches
so it is a significant concern in a
press release Google and Ascension say
they are fully committed to a robust
data security and protection F
and fully compliant with HIPAA the
Health Insurance Portability Act of 1996
that protects patient privacy Dixon says
more has to be done I do think that
there is room for having a independent
third party taking a look at what's
happening at that health information
that's at Google
well Amazon and Apple are also trying to
get a foothold in healthcare Google has
made the biggest strides so far it has a
previous deal with a Mayo Clinic but in
that case any identifying information
had been removed
not so with project Nightingale you got
me with the term lab results are being
shared so how concerned should patients
be that this information is being shared
I think it's a very difficult conundrum
we find ourselves in on the one hand you
can see the value of streamlining
information potentially being able to
better diagnose patients to predict
things that might happen on the other
hand there are certainly risks and you
know that doctor-patient relationship is
one built on trust it's a very secure
safe environment you know patients tell
us things in the office that they don't
tell anybody anybody things about their
spirituality about their social habits
and so to risk that being leaked in some
way at some point it's very scary
parents or doctors neither one of them
were told to make sure yeah why not
solicit feedback ahead of time and say
hey just so you know we're gonna be
sharing it's gonna be great I think it
would have been a lot easier to buy in
if you agreed and said yes I'm giving my
information but to not know and then
have it out there it's concerning yeah
like they got to come up with a way to
change the system it's very
disconcerting to know that yes I go in
the privacy of your office yep
anything that's shared to know that it
could be leaked anywhere that's right
and it may make patients not want to
share as yes which is the wrong thing
yeah how are you feeling I'm fine right
thank you very much